yeah so thank you it's i was extremely
excited when uh i learned that this
class was happening at all just because
i've been doing
things that i would consider audio ar
for uh you know 12 years now probably um
i'm very old so don't don't ask me any
particulars but
and uh it was just it's so exciting to
be at a time now where things are
becoming um i don't know if i'd call it
mainstream yet but at least getting to
the point where people are talking about
it and teaching it and uh and uh you
know so i was excited to learn from what
you guys are uh going through uh in
learning in this class and uh to
contribute to the extent that i can so i
don't know what just happened there but
i'm gonna press
play again on my
my back
um
i have uh i'm a sound artist um and
technologist and i've been um doing work
with uh uh
what i would call audio ar for quite a
while as i was saying i work a lot with
spoken human voices and on the
contributory part of my work is that i i
generally
do work that um that feeds off of
responses and commentary that i get from
people who are experiencing the work so
i ask people questions they i record
their answers or they record themselves
and then those those uh sort of feed
back into these evolving works that are
often location based and uh and sort of
change over time and and often have a
musical underpinning as well so i'll i'm
going to talk about a whole bunch of
examples of my work and then talk a
little bit about the technology that
i've developed to um to support some of
that work which is
what i would call a contributory audio
ar framework platform um called
roundware and
then i'm hoping there'll be plenty of
time to
to ask questions because that's probably
going to be the most useful and
interesting part perhaps so feel free to
jump in anytime if you have questions
but there will be time at the end either
way so
let me just leap in i don't know what
order things are gonna happen here but
i'm gonna go for it whatever it is okay
so so what is roundware i just uh
mentioned a little bit about what
ramware is but essentially roundware is
a
a framework um or a platform depending
on your preference there that allows for
the creation of
basically it allows to overlay any kind
of physical landscape with a layer of
audio
and it's actually multiple layers of
audio that can interact with each other
and i have this quick sort of example
here of of the basic elements of what a
roundware installation covers um so
let's say you wanted to do something on
the uh the the mall in dc
and uh this is just
this is the mall and the first thing
roundware allows you to do is create
sort of regions of what i call ambient
music uh well i don't call it i mean
lots of people call things ambient music
but um it's a it's sort of a continuous
layer of ambient sound and those right
now they're just circles that are drawn
here you could have any shapes you want
and basically the way to think about it
is each of these circles has a different
underlying um
ambient uh it doesn't have to be ambient
but often in my case it's ambient
soundtrack and as you perf as you walk
from one to the next you know one fades
out the other one fades in etc you know
here you're you've got all three of them
playing so this is a way to compose a
piece of music or a
audio experience of some sort that
really it is very highly dependent on
how somebody traverses an actual terrain
so
this is quite simplified in the sense
that there are only circles here right
right now roundware started out you
could only do circles i've since moved
on to polygons which is very exciting
and so you can draw just you know a
block or you could just draw right
around here on a map and basically
assign any
any um audio to that and in addition to
the
the sort of underlying continuous layer
of audio there are two types of
sort of what i call momentary audio that
that can be interspersed within that
they're usually smaller bits and they're
usually
pieces of audio that kind of play once
like you right you get into the area and
then it's triggered it will play once
and then it'll be done as opposed to
sort of a looping ambient situation
and those can be either curated by the
person creating the project you know me
or whomever is using ramware
or they can be added using the same app
they can be added by
the people who are experiencing the
project so these red ones are to
indicate that there's another kind of
type of content which is a dynamic type
of content which happens
over time when a particular piece is
installed so if i installed this in dc
on you know january 1st and you know the
app was released and people could wander
around listening to everything which was
the ambient layer and then these yellow
dots and then they added their own on
top of that to respond to various
questions that are asked within the app
and you know depending on what what the
piece is about i can ask questions any
any question i want i could you know
look at the clouds and tell me what you
think and then they could do or you know
tell me uh what this building reminds
you of or you know anything at all
and you know describe the person who
just walked past you or something like
that there are lots of you know
explorations that can be done but the
point is that these red ones are
sort of indicative of of a co-creation
sort of element to what i do a
contributory element and a
way in which i lose
control over a lot of what the piece
ends up being which is both exciting and
totally nerve-wracking as as i'm sure
you can imagine but um
it's uh it's a a crucial part of my work
and about
and of what roundware allows because
again roundware was developed obviously
to you know
scratch the own itch that i have my own
itch that i had to uh to create um
uh the pieces so
i will uh keep on going i'm gonna kind
of crank through some of these um some
of the history of where roundware came
from just relatively quickly although
i'm gonna show one video which i think
will be useful
so roundware is actually named because
the first project i did with it was
called round
so
this was a project for a museum outside
of new york
called the aldrich contemporary art
museum and they asked me to
come in and do something that would
be some sort of
slightly resembling an audio tour but
not be an audio tour because they really
didn't like the general approach of
audio tours to sort of tell you what
you're supposed to think about the
artwork et cetera et cetera and
i decided that what i would do was
basically create a sort of soundtrack
for the museum so when people are
wandering around they could hear that
and then um infuse it with comments that
people made about the artworks in the
museum that would be heard when you were
standing in front of that artwork so you
could be standing in front of a painting
and
you could hear um you know the
curatorial curator smart remarks about
the painter but then about the painting
but then you could also hear a
six-year-old's comments about the
painting as well and
the idea of sort of democratizing and
making um
making art into something that i feel it
should always be which is that anybody
can appreciate it anybody can like or
dislike anything and you don't need to
have a phd in in art history or some
kind of you know critical discourse to
uh to have that sort of appreciation so
that's where round game roundwork came
from the the title the round round is is
sort of
the reason i named it that which is
somewhat useful perhaps to to understand
is
um first of all king arthur's round
table
where everybody sits around a round
table and nobody's nobody's opinion is
sort of more important than others and
then second of all the notion of um
a musical round you guys know what a
musical round is like row row rower boat
and everybody's kind of everybody's
singing together but kind of in an
offset way which i think is is somewhat
what roundware enables you to create so
i'm going to
hope that this is actually going to play
a video
this was a piece that i did at the de
cordova
sculpture garden museum out in lincoln
outside of boston and
it was one of the first pieces using
roundware and i think it will give you a
little bit of an idea of what roundmark
can actually do and what my work is like
so
escapes piece is i think of it as a
musical composition that is a spatially
related musical composition
[Music]
and the volumes of those
parts um fade up and down depending on
how close you are to where the center of
that particular musical part is
okay let's walk
the music is changing now
yeah we get these bells more towards the
entrance of the museum it's more of a
sort of melodic part a very slow melody
all the music is based on some of the
topographic characteristics of the park
itself
[Music]
i know that it is oh there's some voices
hey there goes a chipmunk
right where i'm standing some guy saw a
chip
there goes the chipmunk again um which
could have been a chipmunk from two
weeks ago yes it could have absolutely i
think it's kind of fun to think about
where that chipmunk is right now
[Music]
[Music]
wow
so that guy went and did this
they stuck their head into
this open glass dome that's part of the
structure and these are the acoustics he
was talking about
and now i'm doing it too
you might not have done that otherwise
i'm pretty sure i wouldn't dab
[Music]
i
am
weak
being recruited into the israeli army
i'm going to be a soldier i'm very
scared
pretty excited
being here is pretty peaceful i guess
compared to what i'm about to go through
good luck to me
oh wow
this rain
that's right
and they recorded the rain and left it
here for us
it's not raining though right now
that's pretty cool
so um so if you want to make your own
recording
okay i'm looking at this sculpture it
looks like a piece of
like hvac ductwork from a building but
it kind of twists in a way that reminds
me of like a lower intestine
we hit stop and hit stop and then we can
listen to it back
okay i'm looking at this sculpture it
looks like a piece of there i am
like hvac
there were these three elements going on
simultaneously there was the music there
was the rain from god knows when that
was recorded not on a day like today
and then there's me
from just a few minutes ago
[Music]
it looks like a very peaceful garden
the thing i think would would help it
would be a few it would be a few
of one of those type of fish
so
that
should give you a little a little bit of
an idea so that piece started out with
just the music and none of the comments
and then people made the comments over
time which
again that's that's the other sort of
nerve-wracking part of this is when you
start and you know the music is written
to have comments on top of it so it's
not that interesting until commentary
sort of comes in but um you sort of hope
for the best and uh and and hope that
you get you know kids who who like
catfish i don't know it's a type of fish
that are catfish it's very interesting
phrasing but um
it was you know super cute though so um
so that gives you the basic idea i think
hopefully um with the retro iphone and
everything uh
so i'll go through um actually i'm gonna
skip some of these things real quick
here um that's not that's not that's not
okay another audio arp sounds guy this
was a piece i did in christchurch new
zealand um
this was a p they uh
a number of years ago they had a huge
earthquake in christchurch which pretty
much destroyed um
a huge portion of the downtown so the
point the sort of
hope with this piece was to create a
piece in the downtown area and let
people who are residents go sort of
wander through and um
you know reminisce
in part reminisce about what used to
exist in certain places that were you
know unfortunately destroyed but then
also looked to the future and looked and
and sort of talked about well this
this was this but now we have an
opportunity to rebuild and this could
become this and the downtown could
transform into this new
new sort of thing so the idea of having
a location-based piece that allowed
people to make these comments to
actually create the comments when
they're in the sort of you know
emotional space of being there was
extremely important because i think that
that really puts you in the right place
to make you know heartfelt earnest
authentic comments and then also
obviously when other people come by to
listen to those comments they exist in
the place where the person made them so
there's this you know there's this
connection to the to the specific
landscape to that specific location um
on both ends of that uh experience which
which i think is one of the ways that um
that audio ar can be really really
compelling um certainly not the only but
one of the uh one of the great ways that
uh
that you can you know navigate through a
space listening to something and you
know not having your phone in front of
you the whole time uh and uh you know
get that added layer of content so
um another project tributaries this was
a project in newcastle in the uk which
was um
a uh
uh
done for the 100th anniversary of world
war one
the end of world war well sort of the
entire sort of the
they were doing a bunch of the museums
over there were doing a bunch of exhibit
exhibitions on world war one and they
wanted to try to bring back some voices
from back then and bring back some uh
some of the experiences that uh people
who are live then went through obviously
there's not many recordings from back
then so we kind of had to
reproduce some of that but they did have
a lot of texts a lot of diaries a lot of
other you know their weather reports and
all that kind of stuff so there was ways
that we could you know we got a
present-day weather
weather person to uh to voice the
weather reports from 100 years ago and
sort of distribute those throughout the
city and and kind of create this
connection between um
this historical moment and the present
day and i think again i think audio
and audio are in particular is a great
i think can be very effective at
connecting compressing time if you will
connecting different points in time
whether it's yesterday and today you
know i experienced something in this
location now and somebody will have a
new experience in this location tomorrow
and and there's sort of a constancy of
location but uh but a a breadth of time
i think can be quite interesting and you
know whether it's a day a week a month
or 100 years i think there's a lot of
ways of kind of
jumping into that and and doing some
exploring so
tributaries that was probably the
biggest aspect of that project that um
it was new and different for me um
so i'll get a little into behind the
scenes stuff um
not
too much but uh
so as i as i mentioned before ram ware
is a software platform rate is open
source i don't know what um
i'm not going to get very really hardly
at all technical so i'm sure you guys
are
um but feel free to ask more technical
questions if you have them but ramware
essentially is a
client server the server sits in the
cloud all the audio is sort of stored up
there database all that kind of stuff
and then
there are various clients that can talk
to that server via the ramware api
this is a somewhat old diagram so
forgive some of the stuff that's a
little outdated but essentially just
what i said you know
database
some uh
software on the server that used to do
the audio mixing the audio mixing is now
work moved to the clients um
but the basic point is that there's a
database of of of uh audio that is all
geotagged and the clients access that
data
with the knowledge of course of where
the client is at any given time how the
client's moving
where you know all of that information
and that
that enables the generation of a dynamic
stream of audio that is you know unique
for any individual any client will have
a unique
um unique stream of audio whether it's
um
uh you know coming from the client or
being generated locally and it all
depends on how they're walking around
how fast they're going
in some cases what direction they're
looking
i know you guys are
fully aware of all the bose
stuff uh the frames and whatnot
so that's a sort of high level
architecture on the uh this is you know
way more than i want to actually go
through as i mentioned the mixing is now
done on the client side so just the
component parts of the audio stream are
downloaded and then the client does the
mixing which allows me to do
um more
less latent activities such as you know
when you when you look in a different
direction you don't want to have to wait
for the buffering time to have your
audio actually change accordingly so
um client-side mixing makes a lot more
sense and is something that
you know that we've moved to that the
ios
framework has uh moved to that and uh as
has the web the web app framework
android is a little behind um
budgetary problems
you know how it is open source projects
when you get somebody when i you know
when i get an enthusiastic roundwork
developer
to uh participate then that will catch
up i think but um
but yeah so frameworks for ios you can
you know put it into any ios app you
want and it basically just implements
the ram where api allows for
the generation of these streams and the
communication with the with the server
this is a diagram of of the playlist so
essentially at any given time
there's a dynamic playlist that
roundware generates
which determines what
of those assets will play back for the
person and the assets are if you
remember the diagram before the small
dots like the small
you could be in a spot where there are
100 assets you don't want to hear them
all at the same time obviously you want
to have some kind of capacity for
filtering um and whatnot so here's a
here's just a sort of high level view of
the the filtering that's possible you
have all the assets on the top
and then
you know for a particular project then
you can filter them by tags there's
basically it's you know sort of very
simple metadata kind of um tags that are
grouped by categories you know if you're
which question are you responding to
are you an adult or a child if you might
want to
if you care about that um you know
what's your favorite color i mean you
know it could be anything um and then
there are location-based filters you
know based on where you're located based
on how frequently whether you heard the
the asset recently
and you know if it's been blocked for
some reason then there's ordering and
prioritization all that kind of stuff so
again i don't want to go into huge
detail because we don't have a ton of
time but um
it's important obviously to be able to
filter content to be able to create the
kind of experiences that you want and um
some of this content filtering is sort
of automatic and others are you know can
be exposed to the to the user
based on what you want um
so in some cases i might want people to
be able to
say i want to hear only comments that
museum visitors have made versus
curatorial comments in other cases i
might want to enforce that those are
mixed with each other to make some kind
of point for example
um so here's a few other types of um
these are kind of different listening
modes if you will
that roundware supports
the traditional
mode is you know when you're within the
range of a particular asset you can it
becomes part of the playlist so right
here these three are in range they're
either circles or you can have a polygon
for assets as well that's pretty
straightforward you know what whatever
you're close to you can hear
the global listen just makes everything
available no matter where you are that
can be very effective at times um for
certain types of projects um or at
certain times within the experience of a
project you could switch to global mode
and then switch back if you wanted
range listening allows for you to um
create
some different sort of uh
approaches of listening to stuff that's
at different distances from you so
there's a minimum and a maximum distance
and you can i've done some
experimentation with you know lift your
phone up and it point you know it sort
of lets you listen to stuff that's
farther away from you and you point it
downwards it brings the stuff closer so
again that's a way that you can
determine what content you're listening
to and that's that's useful if you
create
projects that don't have content
everywhere and you want people to still
be able to listen they can just expand
their range
and then directional listening again
this is what bose
frames do but also the imu and your
phone does so if you
you know if you take your phone when
you're listening to the app and you just
move it around you can give yourself a
certain arc and
and listen to the content that in this
case these three guys would be available
you can combine these in different ways
you know you can use the distance
minimum and maximum distance with the
range you can
you know combine these sort of
approaches in different ways
so um
i'm not going to demo the web admin
because i don't think that's very
exciting but i'm happy to answer
questions about that
and
you know we're coming up on 4 30 here so
i thought um i would be
it would probably be better for you guys
to have me stop blabbing a lot and um
perhaps dive into what is most
interesting to you guys hopefully
something
um and uh we can go from there is that
that cool that work for you guys i can
certainly talk about more projects but
i'd love to hear what what questions you
guys have and i can i can certainly
demonstrate stuff as well um
if uh if you want
questions
comments
there's got to be something it's gotta
be
one of our first game ideas that we
haven't ended up pursuing was actually
gwen's idea
but uh was this like
murder mystery where you have to go to
different locations to get different
clues
to hear different clues like the
the idea was like you'd go back in time
and hear something relevant to whatever
case you're trying to solve
that sort of thing
yeah that's super cool yeah that's that
sounds like it would be
an application
totally yeah no i love that idea um i
think uh that the time traveling thing
is is as i was mentioning before i think
that can be really helpful both
you know you can create sounds you know
you could have a horse and buggy driving
by whatever you know you could have like
period type sounds going if you wanted
to sort of really make somebody feel
like they've gone back in time but then
you can also
each user
yes you would that would probably be a
set of tags you would assign different
tags to different stories you could have
story a story b story c and people would
choose which order could be assigned one
of those three and then that would
segment the content based on
based on what they wanted but yes going
going to a particular location sort of
gathering
more information or something like that
for the murder mystery um is is
definitely something that that uh that
ramware could do it's actually funny one
um actually that escapes piece this case
piece
that i showed the video of
people um started making up their own
sort of games with it um and one one
person sort of did kind of what you're
saying it wasn't a murder mystery by any
stretch but they went to sort of
a random place and said you know go to
the
corner of the parking lot to receive
further instructions or something like
that and then they went over there and
then they
proceeded to talk about the further
instruction and then they
you know and
it it was kind of a game within within
the piece which was
you know not i didn't have anything to
do with that it was it was uh you know
somebody taking their own initiative to
sort of figure that out which um
which i thought was great other other
whole bunch of kids talked about zombies
and stuff they were like i'm hiding
beneath this sculpture
the zombies are coming and then this
this this story of zombies actually
continued over
over months um and
with different people like different you
know like
all the zombie fans kind of came
together and there was this one area of
the sculpture park that kind of turned
into zombieland and
um and then at the end you'll be very
glad to know the helicopters came and
landed and everybody was saved so nobody
died but um i mean obviously the zombies
are sort of i don't know what they are
i'm not going to make a comment i'm not
gonna come down one side of that
argument but um
but it's just it's one of those things
where when you open up your um
work to
this kind of um potential interaction
with it you sometimes get really
really neat kind of takes on it that you
uh you know i mean i certainly didn't
think
to create some kind of zombie scenario
um
but it's wonderful and it's it's uh you
know it kind of adds to the um to me it
adds to the excitement of of sort of
creating these pieces i i am
you know my work is very
you know i guess maybe it's a fear of
ever of ever having something be done
but it's there's something about um
knowing that um things can you know can
be sent out into the world and kind of
take on uh their own uh their own life
if you will
much like a zombie no um and uh
and uh and and kind of you know get this
level of creativity or level of input
that i couldn't do on my own you know i
i really get tons of inspiration from
people who come in and uh
and do stuff so yeah i think that that
idea is certainly one that would be um
well
suited for round where um you know i
have dreams of ramware becoming a a sas
at some point it is not yet it is kind
of requires a little more technical um
uh
involvement to set up the server and
then get the client talking so it's not
you know all the code is there it's just
a matter of um kind of going through
those those uh
steps um there's a demo roundware app
that can be used for sort of testing
stuff um which is pretty handy if you
just want to go out and make com you
know make recordings in certain
locations and then sort of see how it
how it works
that can be done that's
uh the ios version is the uh
a good place to do that but i think that
idea would definitely be um
you know roundwork could certainly help
at least get the basics going on that
question yes you know you show up a
little bit of the scape's user interface
the end user what you can record and
just pretty much just drop a sound
that has some radius
but then you also showed all this other
capacity of direction and like minimum
maximum radius is like how much
of that do you see
being useful to expose to kind of like
the
most fundamental part of
the the most difficult part of the thing
yeah
and how much of it is just like too
complex and he is off-putting
yeah i to date i've exposed very little
of it um and that's a really good
question it is something i think a lot
about because i do want
it to remain simple for the end user
that's why you know there's like two
buttons it's listen or speak and that's
kind of obviously within speak there's a
few steps that you need to do to what
questions you want to respond to and
whatnot but
it's fairly fairly straightforward in
that regard and
exposing more
does cause some problems sometimes so
i've experimented a little bit with
adding additional filtering capacity
but having it
sort of semi-hidden not really hidden
but like it isn't
it's like behind a button instead of you
know you hit a button then you open up
oh here are some filters i can do and
the filters have a default state which
is basically listen to everything and
then you can you can kind of specify
from there become a super user of sorts
if you if you want the user choosing
their listening experience based on
eliminating things that you don't want
to hear
in this case yes yes i like to start
with the broad
set if you start with nothing then
people are going to get confused because
they won't you know so kind of starting
broad and then narrowing down um as far
as the other um the other sort of
listening modes and everything goes
that's that's more of a kind of um you
know
set up the project that way one way or
the other and and if you're seeding the
project with a certain amount of content
you know some like the skates piece was
seated with basically no content i
allowed people to come in and do
whatever they wanted the tributaries
piece
i created a lot of content myself and i
put it out there um and uh you know the
weather reports and diary entries and
you know
uh you know
machinists shop logs i mean stuff like
that that was historical material i
could create that and then i could place
that where i wanted and i could create
the shapes and i could do anything like
that um the thing that i think actually
the the the the scenario in which i
think
exposing more to an end user that would
be most appropriate would be
something that i'm sort of i'm working
on now which is um
enabling the app to be more of uh to be
a more
to be a different type of creation tool
so so so the person creating the
experience would be able to go
and say you know create a recording and
then walk around a closed polygon that
they want that recording to exist in for
example um
and and do sort of other other
manipulations be able to move stuff
around to be able to adjust so you're
really in the actual physical location
that the piece is going to be
experienced when you're creating it
because i think that's
that's a far cry from sitting at your
computer at a google map and drawing
something like i think this is where it
is but i'm not really sure and i don't
really know if this is going to work so
you do that i always find myself doing
that and then going out
and listening and then going back in and
then going it's like this back and forth
can be very frustrating so so i think
the exposure of more in-depth sort of
i don't know if you want to call them
editing tools or just or just sort of
experience
modifying tools i think
i think makes more sense for
sort of more of the creator side of
things
of course end users are creators to a
certain extent because they're adding
their own or they have the option of
having their own content but um
but it's a good question because it's i
think it's a constant balance and maybe
when people get more familiar with the
overall idea of audio ar then
and then we'll be able to push a little
farther in that direction but right now
i my experience has been that people
when explaining it to them it was
wonderful when pokemon go came out for
me because i could even though this
really isn't pokemon go there is an
element of
hey it's like pokemon go except instead
of finding pokemon you're going around
and you're finding little pieces of
audio and those are playing and it's you
know
and you can add right pokemon you can't
you can't spawn your own um pokemon
really at this point so
um but that was a nice thing to sort of
give me a context within which to talk
about this stuff um despite the obvious
differences but
but perhaps when ar generally and maybe
audio ar gets to the point where
everybody kind of understands that it
exists and there are possibilities
on a base level then you know we'll be
able to push things farther
but yeah i think there's a ton of stuff
with the directional and that's why you
know that the uh
you know bose imu enabled headphones or
frames and you know i know that there
are other other manufacturers doing
stuff as well
and i think it's going to be really
exciting uh for sure or i mean airpods
or you know i think they've got imus or
some semi-imu the new airpod pros have
something they certainly have
accelerometer in them so i don't know
well yes right because you can test them
yeah cause you could tap them and i i
don't know what they're gonna you know
what kind of apis are going to open up
on that but
it seems like
people are thinking about that stuff
wearables hearables that i don't know if
i'm too into that phrase but it's uh it
seems to be what people are using
somewhat now but
but yeah for me the more hardware that
companies put out that i can experiment
with the better it's great because
i certainly can't build hardware on my
you know i tried strapping an imu to my
you know like
is a major failure
um but uh i am i'm not really a hardware
guy so
more questions more
comments more things you would like me
to show i can
go to
a uh
just a yeah take question what is the
precision where you
uh
delineate where where the sound will
play is it
how exact is it well ramware is is what
i would call location
um
determinate it's sort of it's agnostic
to what where it gets its location
information from so
i you note i showed you mainly outdoor
projects because
we all know the problems with gps
indoors we also know the gps is
the only sort of ubiquitous location
you know essentially free location
technology that exists right now
so so so we have gps error bars right
now which inside a building are you know
way too big to make it useful i have
done a lot of experimentation with other
you know interior
you know systems whether they be
beacon based or
you know magnetic field based or visual
positioning systems but at the end of
the day roundware just takes at this
point roundwear just takes two
coordinates it roundmer doesn't have a z
axis at this point
but adding that isn't that isn't a huge
huge leap but i haven't bothered to add
it there's no point until i can get
something that actually gives me useful
z data to uh to actually base something
on but it would be super cool if you
know you get uwb systems which are like
you know
ultra wideband it's like so it's like
you can get like millimeter level and
then you could like raise your phone up
and you could stand up and sit down and
get whole new levels of of ambient sound
i mean it could be totally amazing but
unfortunately
you know roundware depends on the
systems that are built by large
companies and governments that i don't
have any control over your experience
with implementing this
museum park walk or
art exhibit
did it feel like it connected
spatially
and
conceptually so
um it felt very connected in the demo
or he must have been talking about this
particular thing
uh but was that the experience when you
when you implemented it as well that
yeah people really
can't see what object they're talking
about or does it sort of
pop up in the wrong place sometimes
it would be
unfair of me to say that it was always
fine because it certainly wasn't
sometimes gps gets wacky and of course
the the error bars get multiplied
because you you make a recording and
there's an error bar associated with
that and then you're listening to the
recording there's another error bar
associated sometimes those can
destructively interact which is great
other times not so certainly there are
times when weird stuff happens i think
generally you know i was pretty aware of
what the error bars were when i was
when i was creating the experience so
i sort of could set things up to a
certain extent um understanding uh
understanding that and kind of guiding
the experience such that it would work
relatively well with that
and i will also say that as an artist i
kind of have it a little bit easier
because people are a little more willing
to be um you know with aesthetic
experiences that are a little more
willing to be uh
sort of forgiving about stuff like that
so if you're talking about something
that is maybe over there you'd be like
oh the artist wanted me to walk over
there and you know i mean if you're if
you're in a a generous kind of
interpretive mode that can work i also
do i will say that a lot of times
little gps hiccups can actually be
really interesting because
um if you're walking by and somebody's
like
this happened to me in the escapes
project just to use that as an example i
was walking by and somebody was like
i'm standing inside this ring of trees
and i'm looking up towards the sky and
it's really
it reminds me of you know my
grandfather's house up in maine where i
had this similar situation i was like
i'm not in the ring of trees right now
i'm just walking out in this field so it
made me look around and i was like oh
you know
30 feet that direction was in fact
something that looked like a ring of
trees and it got me to go into it
whereas so i think there is something
really nice about sort of
this
audio are generally being able to kind
of pull you in different directions or
guide you or or encourage or whatever
words you want but um to get you to
explore a little more
by um you know by by kind of giving you
information that is pertinent to a spot
when you're not quite at that spot yet
um for example and i i know that might
seem like an excuse for gps you know
errors but
sometimes they can be nice of course
sometimes they can be
inappropriate and bad but
yeah that's you know when you when you
open yourself up to
you gotta open yourself up to the the
goods and the bads but um
but yeah i'm just super excited for the
day when positioning interior
positioning is accurate enough to um to
really do something
where
you know
you can place sound objects walk around
them and and you know understand uh have
them feel like they've been spatialized
and
and really kind of
get a much more true to reality kind of
experience but
you guys probably know more about how
close we are to that than i do but
my uh from from where i sit exciting
stuff is happening but um it's still i
mean the big guys are all working on it
right i mean
spatial computing is like
everybody wants their spatial engine and
amazon is doing their thing and you know
niantic of course is well into it magic
leap has got the whatever i don't know
all the
the magic verse is that what they call
it i never know what magic
neither do i neither do i but it seems
like they're spending a lot of money and
doing they got good people doing stuff
so
yes they got neil stevenson doing stuff
so i mean they'll be they got some
content possibilities so
um
so yeah i mean it's it's super exciting
but we're definitely dependent on the
you know systems that
that are
out of out of my control out of most
people's control
but i think if you work within those
constraints you can still create some
pretty cool stuff
so
other questions
yes
for my project i wanted to make
something that people could like
potentially contribute poetry
to like a location so i think this might
be really helpful with that
yeah yeah that's that's very cool yeah
poetry um
that
i think poetry
can have some wonderful obviously a lot
of the the language can be very sort of
you know physically as you could
put you in a place and it would be nice
to actually be in that place too yeah i
did i did a piece it's no longer
available
because of the inexorable you know
progress of new ios versions and whatnot
but i i did a piece in harvard yard that
used
as the source material it used all of
the not all but used a bunch of audio
that um the woodbury poetry room at
harvard had they've had a poetry series
for like
100 years of poets coming in and reading
their works so they had recordings of
like robert frost and william carlos
williams and
ezra pound i mean people like really old
amazing recordings of these actual poets
reading their work um and then they have
more contemporary poetry uh poets as
well and i took those and i kind of
sliced them up line by line and then
distributed them around in different
places so i had like all the first lines
of the poem
in a certain area so if you went to this
area you could hear
first line after first line after first
line then you could go somewhere else
and hear all the last lines it was very
made it very abstract and the poets
probably would
be very upset with me if they found out
about this but
um
it was you know it was a it was a
remixing of of that um and it you know a
spatial remixing which um
which was pretty fun to do but i loved
your idea so were you thinking of having
people read their own poetry or or
something along those lines so so write
upon that
related to a certain location and then
go to that location and kind of recite
it sort of thing or i could imagine if
you want to share any more thoughts
yeah
oh like almost almost like
like improv or something like like all
this oh yeah that could be really
that could be really great yeah so
so yeah the question would be i mean the
you know in a round more context that
would be you know open the app press
speak
recite it you know make up a poem right
now and then you just press record and
you
record it and then upload it to the
cloud and then whenever somebody else
came by they could uh
they could um you know they could hear
that and then you'd have the ability of
course as an administrator in that case
to
listen and
move the recording or make the area
bigger or you know those sorts of things
if you if you were to to want to do that
but that could be a a wonderful way of
kind of
it would be a nice way to traverse the
city right you kind of wander through a
city and you hear
residents
improvised poetry at
uh you know sort of you know at
crosswalks or wherever like that's a
that's a cool idea
and you had a lot of uh you you've been
working a lot on prompts yeah like
get people who will not necessarily
be able to compose a whole pool up on
the fly to be able to stop like
that's really smart to think about that
because that's really hard like even if
i mean poetry is like particularly hard
but even for me being like to say
anything is sometimes hard so i always
think about the what questions i i ask
and
i usually have some question that's like
so broad that it's
you know
that anybody could do it like you know
just
tell a story about your day i don't know
look at the you know
look at the ground and tell me what it
reminds you i mean i don't know i'm just
sorry i'm making bad examples right now
but something that's very broad
to uh i mean literally it could just be
share something you know
say something
and then as i go down the list i sort of
get get into more details because i find
that some people
freak out when they have a super broad
question they're like uh what do you
mean something what does that mean you
always say something they are like much
happier being like given instructions
like
look at a tree near you and
describe it
then they're like okay i can do that
there's a tree
record you know the tree is quite tall
and it's got lots of branches and leaves
right now are green but they're starting
to turn yellow
that some people are much more
comfortable with that um
so in a poetry context that could be
really interesting like what are some
prompts that you've come up with thus
far that you've because that's a big
challenge that's a challenge
yeah like right now i've just been
thinking about like sounds so
um it wasn't necessarily
like a poem about sound
but ask like what sounds can you hear
right now and like like looking really
good too
and for like one test i asked them to
write a poem about a different subject
based on the sounds they heard
you mean
like a poem about sound that isn't about
what that sound is actually like what it
reminds you is that what you're saying
sorry i'm
okay
like the theme is not necessarily the
sound itself right yeah so what it
reminds you of or what it
you know
maybe points towards or something like
that yeah
yeah
no that's great to use sound as a poetry
is such a
you know
in my mind poetry is meant to be red
it's meant to be you know it's got all
the rhythms and everything really come
out when you
when it when it gets into the the audio
from just the written page i mean the
written page can be really interesting
too but it's uh um
that's uh
yeah but it's hard it's hard to just
make up a poem
and it must rhyme
uh yes don't yeah
a little bit more fruitless yes that's
good that's good yes free form is uh
i'm always impressed with like uh like
free form like
you know like rap battles and stuff like
that people like i mean like obviously
eminem is like you know the eight mile
thing it's just like oh my gosh how do
they
come up with this stuff like and i know
a lot of it is i know there are
strategies and techniques that kind of
make it more doable but it's um my brain
doesn't work that way i can't just
although it sounds like it right now
that i can just talk forever but uh
i i don't always uh don't always
uh not always able to you right and
right
away your sdks yes
yeah
right oh that reminds me i i should also
mention that um i have uh
started um a new website called
audioar.org
um which
oh great great great so so so the site
is in its infancy right now i started it
with a couple colleagues a couple
journalists
and fran who came here a few months ago
friend panetta a month ago to uh talk to
you guys
british
probably remember because her very
perfect british accent which is
um
uh
[Music]
so she's been doing audio air stuff
obviously as you know for a while too so
we started this
site just to kind of try to collab try
to collect different practitioners in
the area and try to it felt like
something was starting companies
obviously bose and you know amazon and
apple and others are getting interested
and and we thought it would be a nice
place to sort of um let practitioners
and um and technologists and academics
and other people kind of
share um share their experiences things
that work things that didn't work and
just sort of uh give
and you know let people know when
projects are happening and whatnot so
we're we're kind of ramping up on that
and um
philip has agreed to be interviewed for
that at some point whenever i get myself
um
in gear i promise i will and i'm looking
forward to that but yeah i know you're
like please forget
um but uh but yeah any projects you guys
do and um you know we'd love to uh uh
you know think about getting getting
stuff up there because i do think it's
uh
um you know i think this class is
evidence of the fact that it is
becoming a real thing um which is which
is really exciting so i'm super excited
to hear what to hear to experience what
you guys uh
choose to do with the um
with uh you know with the class is it is
there a project there are project is a
project sort of a deliverable for the
class is that right so um
there will be
a
presentation we need to discuss that
before you leave when it's going to
happen
because there are possible changes there
but there will be a presentation at the
end of the class
uh
francesca will
hopefully attend some people from both
will attend if you can come that way oh
cool
yeah
we'll spend the
next two weeks
thinking through how to
disseminate our
insights from the class yeah so there
will be something online i dare say but
we will try to decide that together
exactly what form it will take
so there will be something we will leave
a trace
well to the extent possible we'd love to
amplify that message on on audiohour.org
if it's you know possible but we can we
can obviously talk about that but but
yeah so if you guys have any ideas about
things to include or practitioners or
whatever please feel free to reach out
because
we are super open and want to
learn from each other so
i just
so we're running out of time but i'm
very curious about one aspect of the
system
[Music]
is
is it
dynamic in any way that
people who make contribution could
actually change
parameters or aspects of the experience
for other people beyond just the sound
basically so
an example would be like if there's a
lot of people
leaving a i don't know why i call them
decided to call themselves races but if
a lot of people leave sound traces in
the same
location can the system detect detect
that and decide to play
sort of a
more multi-layered ambient
uh soundtrack in that area or something
is there's some way of being aware of
what's being input
that's a that's a really
interesting area to think about um i
think the simple answer right now is is
no in the sense that ram where doesn't
um
i mean
ram where you can choose
how many simultaneous voices can play
and therefore
if you say well three simultaneous
voices can play if three are available
then in that sense if there's a location
where people add more
then that will be a location where
potentially three will most likely if
there's a hundred in this spot you'll
probably have three playing altogether
at any given time that's not the music
layer or whatever that's just the the
the
so whereas if you have a spot that only
has one available even though three
could potentially play at the same time
only one will ever actually play because
there's only one available so that's a
very very rudimentary aspect of what
you're talking about and that's the only
sort of at least if i'm understanding
you correctly that's that's the only
thing that roundworth sort of does
currently but i love this idea i hadn't
thought about this i love this idea of
more more activity kind of the heat map
heats up and something changes with
we're always going to think about
this is there a way i can program this
as a participant you know like because
so
so even there might be a way even if you
don't know it uh you know injecting
codes somewhere by yeah who knows uh you
know uh
overloading the database or something
but uh
yeah it's it's just
i think there's some potential there
somewhere and like what
it could be very advanced like the words
you say could actually be
understood by the system and it could
change things but
yeah i've been then yeah then you're
halfway to the matrix i've
i don't know it's super i've been
thinking about you know the first step
to that obviously is sort of getting
some kind of accurate translation you
know or transcription service you know
automated so that and then and then you
could get to the point where you could
search for only play me only play me
commentary that's that uses the word
love and then you could walk around and
get this whole experience with just um
and then you do sentiment analysis and
then it's like only give me the the
comments that
feel love
even though they don't say love but they
feel it um
so i think those are super exciting
areas to look into
i just want to know what the zombie
people would do with something like that
yeah where they can sort of affect the
system itself or the zombies themselves
yeah
i mean
this is this is very very very important
but no i i i love that idea um and
yeah so uh it's open source right
time i think this was really helpful
actually we have one team who are out
today because of medical emergency or
basically doing the kind of pokemon go
go music oh cool so
uh we'll definitely have them look at
your system and they great
i would guess will wanna use it
well feel free to reach out i can you
know again depending on the level of
technical
skill
and time involved or time available it's
um you know i can recommend different
approaches to to things but all the code
is there the server's written in python
using django obviously ios is swift and
um the web stuff is is uh very nascent
right now but it is
um it's all you know javascript sort of
modern day javascript stuff so to the
extent yes
but do you is there a way to like
procedurally generate a location
for
a sound fight or is it
totally tight
um can you describe what like what
scenario you would like what what input
would you be taking to so pokemon go so
this is has to do with the pokemon go
but like audio music
um project that chuck is doing um
yeah
uh checking chairs are doing so
um in pokemon go you walk around pokemon
like
spawn
can audio also spawn
probability
based on like a probability yeah um that
is i mean it
that would be
[Music]
the kind of thing that um would be a
relatively small modification for a
particular project i haven't done that
the other thing that i haven't done that
i'm very excited about is
is that they is moving after after their
spawn then they move you you assign a
path and a time whatever and they loop
around or or so then you can just sit in
one place and you can let stuff flow
over you or you can move around and
there's this sort of double
double um interaction in that sense well
it's a single interaction but you know
what i mean double um motion so um that
is also really um that kind of dynamism
i think is very exciting but yeah i like
the idea of of spawning um sort of
popping up based on
you know maybe your previous experience
within the app or or something like that
but
but yeah i think the framework is there
that that you can you know i've been
just adding stuff as we go you know
semi-organic code base in that sense
which is sometimes problematic but um
it's fairly clean so
check it out if you know python you can
jump in and have a look all right
thank you guys so much thank you
you